well next tonight
it should be a progressive hero exiled
at him hiding from Iran's assassin since
2009 she's a ferocious critic of the
Islamic Republic's brutality and his war
on women instead she's also on the
receiving end of criticism herself being
accused of islamophobia for opposing the
compulsory hijab Iran has faced massive
protests this year after Manatee police
killed a 22 year old woman who refused
to wear one well she does me now so
great to see you thank you so much
you're a hero to so many of us for the
way that you stood up to this we talk a
lot about human rights
there's very few places in the world
where there is a bigger assault on human
rights and women's rights than Iran
right now we just woke up with the news
of executions I mean there was a little
girl which I just published a video of
her on my Twitter account she was
begging the Islamic Republic officials
in Iran not to execute her father what
happened they did two young men got
executed for the crime of criticizing
Islam and Prophet Muhammad and then they
call me aslamophobic come on
as a woman who grew up on their Sharia
law that showing my hair is a crime can
get me killed I deserve I mean I had the
right to be scared of sharia laws to be
scared of Islamic Republic and be honest
with you
phobia is irrational my fear and the
fear of millions of Iranian women women
of Afghanistan of Taliban and Islamic
Republic is rational I was saying the
same thing in Afghanistan where that
overnight shameful overnight
fleeing by led by America from
Afghanistan under President Biden led to
total chaos a lot of death but also
basically through millions of Afghan
women back to matalaban wolves and we're
seeing the same thing there my heart is
broken because I see that now uh the
news about women of Afghanistan being
Fade Out the news about the women led
the revolution in Iran being Fade Out
and people think that everything is over
but women are in front line and chanting
women life Freedom they want to
overthrew a gender apartheid resume I
was actually talking uh to people here
in the UK and I wanted to get the public
opinion the attention of British women
and men that think about it a day that
women are being kicked out from a
stadium women get uh killed for showing
their hair getting arrested and raped
for singing for dancing what would be
the reaction of the rest of the world I
mean if it was not women of Iran if it
was not women of uh the Middle East
women in the UK get kicked out from a
stadium what would you do what would
FIFA do you know that it's a gender
apartheid regime completely you know
that by saying all this you're putting a
bigger Target on your back all the time
do you worry about that I mean to be
honest as you hear me I'm very loud
against a terrorists I'm not as scared
of them but let's be very honest it's a
scary when you see a man with loaded gun
in front of your house trying to kill
you the Islamic Republic hired three
Russian mafia
and they were trying to kill me on U.S
soil the FBI arrested them right now
they are in prison but this is scary but
at the same time I'm not carrying any
weapon I'm only 45 kilos that actually
shows you that the Islamic Republic they
are scared of me and millions of women
like I think they are yeah I think they
are and I feel the Iranian women they're
beginning to realize their own power
perhaps collectively yes I mean Iranian
women they are my heroes thank you so
much for calling me hero but my heroes
are in Iran actually they know that
they're facing guns and bullets some of
them get shot in their eyes they're
blinded but they say that you can take
our life you can take our eyes you can
take our bodies but not our hope we are
here to end this what more should the
West be doing Sydney maybe Western women
that's a good question that's a very
good question and that's why I am here
to meet with the members of parliament
here in London and inform them about
what's going on in Iran it's not about
us trying to just save ourselves the
Islamic Republic is a threat to
democracy and we are actually risking
our life to protect democracy across the
globe and I'm not just claiming that
right now the Islamic Republic sending
drones to poutine to kill innocent
ukrainians how ironic the woke left
attack you I mean it's just been my
issue with them about women's rights
generally they're on the wrong side of
history with all this stuff I mean I
still have hope that I can actually
convince them that this is the right
time that you have to support us because
look the Islamic Republic actually hired
Killers here to kill a journalists from
your you know the Iran International
biggest TV Persian TV broadcasting here
they were to Target of the Islamic
Republic so you see if you don't support
our fight against Islamic Republic you
have to face the terrorists on Western
soil so clearly what happened in Vegas
it says that it's gonna stay in Vegas
but what happened in the Middle East in
Iran it's not going to stay there it's
going to infect the rest of the world
here in the UK they're being paid by
euchar government uh having Islamic
Center for what let me be very clear
with you
British people are like British weather
they're not predictable but the Islamic
Republic officials they are predictable
they are here not to express them
themselves they are here to expand their
ideology to uh you know to sponsor
terrorist organization and they are here
to kill innocent Iranians that's why I'm
asking the UK government I hope I can
meet with the UK prime minister yeah
maybe the king to convince them that
this is the time that my people are
risking their lives to protect democracy
you're an incredibly courageous Lady
it's great to have you in here your
passion Rings through and the courage
Rings through I hope people are
listening and watching it thank you I
appreciate it I hope one day I'm going
to invite you to my beautiful country
Iran I would love that I know it's a
beautiful country thank you so much it's
good to see you thank you very much
indeed pleasure that's what courage
looks like and that's why women's rights
are important